[Music]
[Applause]
Diana Rossini's been covering this in
fact uh I was watching what was it
yesterday when it was dueling phones
with Diana and shefty and I was like oh
whoa this is getting serious at least it
looked like it was serious Diana joining
us and she of course part of a sports
center the special feature uh today at
three Eastern on ESPN leading into NFL
live any updates Diana
Dan it's great to be here oh he's just
sucking me for information man so good
to hear your voice uh I first just want
to address that I changed my background
for those listening the last time I was
with Dan I was in Stephen A Smith's
office it wasn't very impressive and I
decided that I wanted to go into the
actual NFL live studio today to just try
to show you I've gotten I've got some
juicer out here now Dan it's it's
incredible someone's like let's help
this girl out so uh I hope you're
impressed can you can you show us more
of the studio there can you show us with
your camera just oh wow that is that is
cavernous
beautiful it's beautiful it is uh
that might be the studio that I built
Diana
you know what I I would guess that that
it is so thank you for that Dan once
again is there a building with my name
on it up there have they done that yet
or is there a plaque or a statue I
haven't been up there in a long time
there is this small
maker right okay
next you're in it just says dan on it
and apparently that that that's what you
got here that's what you left well that
was my parting gift I gave that yeah and
uh that's okay just as long as they
remember me when I'm long gone all right
any updates all right so no updates as
of now right so let's just get to to
this right so look nobody knows for sure
if Aaron is going to hop on the Pat
McAfee show today and make that
announcement
um because we do know that this isn't
completely done yet in terms of the
trade between these teams between the
Jets and and the Packers so it's not
official so while air I'm sure Aaron can
find creative ways to get around it so
I'm curious to see if he'll just
come out here and say yeah I've been
talking to the Jets and that's where I'd
like to play I think it'd probably
behoove him to do that because I know
uh here in the New York area I think
fans are starting to lose their minds a
little bit
um the best way I've described it I
think a lot of these people feel like
they're sitting in traffic going in the
wrong direction in terms of their
frustration with with the situation as
they're waiting for an answer well you
had the wish list report and I don't
know if it's a demand list or just a hey
if you guys would consider this that
would be great they sign Alan Lazard
Mercedes Lewis is probably a year
younger than me uh Randall Cobb is also
thrown in there and then obj wants 20
million dollars a year
wish list or demand list oh it is a wish
list right and it's smart business from
Aaron Rodgers he's got all the leverage
in the world right now and look he's he
said to the Jets here are some guys I
want to play with take a look into this
see if you can get them Nathaniel
Hackett has familiarity with a lot of
these guys as well we could use some
veteran leadership in New York as well
with most you know the core of the Jets
being pretty young at this point so
um I think it's one of those things
where people see a wish list and they
immediately think that means I must have
not all wishes come true right so it
equated to my Amazon wishlist that
thing's packed I'm not getting all that
stuff though you know I mean I send it
to my husband all the time but he
doesn't buy half of it
um you know maybe one or two things so
and he wants obj too and that's kind of
weird so you know some competition there
yeah for sure um but
it from based on the roster it never
looked like they gave him that much of
that power uh so now he has this
opportunity to do that
um and there's there's more on the list
Dan and you're a wonderful interviewer
and I know you're going to try to get me
to tell you the rest of these guys but
I'm gonna try to be disciplined today
and keep it to myself for now
um
but yeah and and look the Jets are
willing to work with him they're trying
to make him happy and also trying to
build the team that they think can be at
its best and some of these players they
agree with that that could make the Jets
better but I think it's pretty obvious
based on this list uh that these are
Aaron's choices
um and we'll see if the Jets will be
able to to fulfill some of these wishes
but when you talk about the wish list
and so why were these names revealed and
the other names that are on the wish
list weren't
truthfully I just decided not to share
them all
oh okay yeah so so I had spoken to some
people
um around the league and also in New
York just about how this was all going
down and
um you know New York has been operating
with
a free agent
list of players that they've been
looking into and then there's one
section of it that Aaron would like as
well
um what is that
Eric when when they met Aaron said here
are some guys I like let's get them
right it doesn't mean he's not going to
the Jets if he doesn't if the New York
Jets aren't able to pay for Odell
Beckham Jr who's got an asking price of
15 to 20 million right now which you
know from having some conversations this
morning with some teams that are
interested in Odell they don't actually
think that's gonna be the number they're
gonna land at you know it's ask for 20
get 10 right it's just the negotiation
tactic that we all know
um but what if the Jets can do it you
know what if the Jets are able to
negotiate this these are some of the
guys he would just like on his team
these are free agents though
does Aaron have players on his wish list
that aren't free agents
I really don't want to come on this show
anymore
how many players are not there are
players that Aaron would like to play
with that he has played with in Green
Bay okay some of them are still in Green
Bay okay
is David bakhtiari
on that list
I think he would love to play with David
bachari they've got it no I just said is
he on the list is he on the list
um
you know I'm not sure I'm not certain on
it but I I know he is a player that that
the Jets know the Jets are well aware
that Aaron Rodgers likes David bakhtiari
okay all right you know but um by the
way what's the hold up here the hold up
uh it's actually between the Packers and
the Jets they are still working out
um the deal compensation compensation
it's not the contract it's it's the
trade so we are waiting for a word that
they've been able to agree
um it's been a back and forth for
over a week now and
it again it's it's why there's also a
chance that when Aaron speaks soon
we actually may not get an answer do I
think he's going to say he's going to
New York I do but there's a chance that
he doesn't because it's not official and
it's not it's not complete and he wants
to make sure
this is all
complete what do the Packers want in
compensation
so we don't know
um
yeah we don't know right now we've heard
a couple little we've heard a couple
of the negotiation things that were
spoken at the negotiation table we'll
call it
um but we don't know for sure right now
so
um you know it'll all come out very soon
but
um I know last time you and I spoke we
were talking about
the Jets perhaps not having to give up a
first rounder
um my colleague Adam schefter who's been
all over the story as well has shared
that
the Packers had thought that maybe they
would want two first round picks from
the New York Jets
um so we're kind of talking to both
sides trying to get an idea of where
they're at but right now we don't know
what leverage do the Packers have
not much
this is what I think is really
interesting because you know we know
that President Mark Murphy we all had
hurt we've all heard the interview by
now and if you haven't he
basically just
at a girl's high school basketball game
shared his thoughts on the future of the
Packers and it was pretty clear it does
not include Aaron Rodgers and as soon as
I heard those words I realized they just
they just showed their hand I mean the
Jets knew that
but you you publicly just said it we
want to move on right
um that's our plan so I'm not sure how
much Leverage
they have now look
the Packers save a lot of money
if they wind up moving Aaron after June
compared to now
and that's going to be really
interesting to keep an eye on this could
possibly and I'm not trying to
uh be dramatic here this could drag out
this really could
um depending on the business side of
this if they're able to work it out or
not
do the Jets want Aaron Rodgers more than
the Packers don't want Aaron Rodgers
how the heck could you measure that does
my ex-boyfriend hate me more than my
husband loves me well
in my scenario definitely ex-boyfriend
needs me more because my husband loves
me about like an age
um especially right now because I
haven't been home in two days I've left
him home with two kids in diapers for
48 hours and you know he stuck with my
mom it's just it's a miserable situation
there at that house uh I have not called
actually because I just don't I just
don't want to hear there's no reason to
there's no reason to no exactly at this
point I'm just digging in Dan I'm like
let me just get it through free agency
here and and you know I look forward to
the weekend of no one talking to me and
my children well I would I would go on
the road for SportsCenter and I had four
kids under the age of seven I would call
home and hope my wife didn't answer but
I would get credit for calling because I
knew it was going to be chaos
yeah and and kids these days I have a
one-year-old and a five month old
um the one-year-old uh yeah
they can't do anything you know for
themselves they need us
and you know my husband works I work
um my mother you know she raised her own
kids she doesn't want to raise babies
like this is a whole other issue I know
you know like it's funny you know
because I I love what I do and free NFL
free agency is my favorite time of year
this is so much fun I'm in awe of my
colleague Adam schefter I love being
part of it I I'm honored he includes me
in this
um
but for me every single time you see me
on TV and I'm talking about this stuff I
I can promise you in the back of my mind
I'm thinking about if when I get home if
my husband's serving me papers
um that basically say move the heck out
so Aaron if you need a home there's a
chance uh in Bergen County a decent home
is available to you because it could be
for sale after this week uh but look I'm
hoping to get some answers here on Aaron
Rodgers soon I think I think it's I
think it's time you know and here's what
happens to Dan as as the journalists
that are covering this
the more time goes the more we dig right
because we're talking about it over and
over and over again yeah um and I just
think that the more this drags out the
more we're just gonna keep digging on it
and it's just
no nobody wants all this information out
who who would
um
so I'm I'm excited to see what Aaron's
gonna say here soon
thanks for joining us more importantly
good good luck with your marriage
if you know anyone single
Diana Rossini ESPN reporter and
contributing to ESPN year round with
their football coverage today at three
Eastern on ESPN leading into NFL live
it's a sports center special probably
reacting to what Aaron says to Pat
McAfee